サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
ではよろしくお願いします
今日はあのお釈迦様の話を聞いて
自分の人生の意味をね
発見したいという目的で皆様聞いていただきまして
本当にありがとうございます
えーと 今日のテーマはね
性格の完成ということで
で ありのままは危ないとね
ということは簡単ですね
ありのままにいるんじゃなくて
我々の性格を完成させなくちゃいけないということです
それにあの 議論するポイントとかたくさん送られてはいただけましたけど
まあそれはほとんど使ってないんです
はい いきなりブッダの話に入りまして
余計な世間的な話を置いておいてね
あの 早く終わりたいと思っています
それから皆様に質問をする時間をあげたいと思っているんです
そういうわけで 人格って何ですか
性格って何ですかとかね
どんな人がどういうふうに言っているのかとか
そういうのは全部もう省略
仏教から見れば このカンマセクタっていうすごい有名な言葉があるんですね
セクタっていうのは自分自身のものということですね
自分が 持っているもの
これはこれは離れません
自分といえば何かあるでということでね
それが業なんですね これ
なかなかセクタスキヤッタというサンスクリット語と呼ぶんですけど
あの なかなか他の言語にはちょっと訳しがたいニュアンスもありますね
一応 自己とは業のことというタイトルで
なぜ生命は同一ではないのでしょうかと尋ねられた時
釈尊はこのように答える
ある人がお釈迦様に質問してきたので
これは中部経典の後半の方に入っているんですね
あのチューラカマユ・バンガスッタというね
その人がまず人間のことを観察して
人間って様々バラバラだよと
美しい人がいるし そうでない人がいるし
長寿の人が短命の人がいるし
豊かな人がいて 貧乏な人がいるし
頭の良い人がいて 頭の悪い人がいるし
何なのか これは と なんで人間様々同一じゃない
おそらくこの人がね インドの一般的にはね
すべて神様が作ったという概念がありましたし
ですから まあなんで一人一人特別に作るんですかね
面倒くさいでしょうと
人間は動物たちを見たら
なんかみんな同じように見えますね
我々にはなかなか区別できません
動物たちを見ると 人間はそうじゃないと言ってるけど
何なのかと はい それに答えたものをですね
業自性という専門用語なんですね
自分特有なものは業です
カンマセクタっていうのは
日本訳する場合は業自性という風に訳するみたい
私の言葉で言えば 自分特有なもの
自分と言えるものと言えば業なんです
体も変化するしね 病気になったりするし
部品捨てたりもするしね
写真撮ってみたら ずーっとなんか自分でしょうか？というね
変わっていくんですね
でもそういうことをいくら変わっていっても
環境は変わるわ もういろんな変化が起こるんだけど
しかし 自分のものといえば
業っていうのは それはもう変わらないんではなくて
それをずっと持っているんですね
そこでお釈迦様のタイトルの言葉はカマッセカタなんですね
次にもっとわかりやすく同義語を使うんですね
2番目の同義語は 生命は業を相続しますと
我々は相続しているんですね
業っていうものは 業から生まれる
要するに私を生んだのは業なんです
これ パーリ語はちょっとはっきりしています
カンマように ようにっていうのは
まああの まあ女性の子供が産む場所を示すものなんですけど
一応 業が生んだということになるんですね
各人 各生命を だから本当の母親は業なんです
家族とは業なんです いつでも自分から離れないで
自分のことを心配して
あれやこれやとやってくれるのが親族
とは業なんですね 家族ではなく親族
業に頼っている 依存している
私たちは業からもう業のおかげで
業に頼って生きているんですね
自分を持ってる業以外
自分を助けて助けることは誰にもできないということになっちゃうんですね
はい これでこの神という概念は
仏教はものすごく扱いさえもしないで捨てちゃうんですね
今 業と言ったのは全部神の仕事なんです
絶対的な神様の仕事なんですね
仏教はもう冗談ですと
これはもう業だよと はい
次に個性という問題に入ってみましょう
各生命の個性を業が作ります
この一人一人が何で違うのかというと
自分の業は自分の業で
他人と分かち合うこともできない
他人の業を自分で受けることもできません
これが特別なんですね
他は何でも人と他人と分かち合えるんだけどね
人の悲しみでもね まあよく考えて
自分でも悲しみになることも可能ですけど
業はどうにもならん 自分のものなんですね
要するに自分というものは実体としてね
仏教では存在しないんだから
だからこの肉体的な組織があって
その 中で業というエネルギーが働いているんですね
癒し 優れているなどの生命の差異は業の仕業です
あの経典でずっと分かりやすく説明していますけど
その経典の説明に行っちゃうと
この正確の方がね ちょっと脱線してしまいますから
そこは あまり触れないことにしました
で ちょっとまあ余分に言うならば
なんで生命は長生きするのかと
それは業で その人は結構過去世で生命を助けてあげたり
命を助けてあげたり 死にかけている人々と協力して
もう生き返るように協力したりとかね
いわゆる命を助けた 命を助けたんだから
そこを影響が自分の心の中に入っちゃって
肉体は問題なく維持するんですね
だから長生きになるんです
では なんで短命になるのかと
生命を いじめたり 怪我させたり
殴ったり殺したりする
いわゆる命に邪魔するんですね
その命に邪魔した業で
自分の命は短命 長く持つことはできません
というふうに結構説明はあるんで
なんで富豪かで生まれるのかと
この人 生命体は過去生で結構人々を助けた人々ではなくて
他の生命にもいろんなものをあげたりして
生きることを助けた ものをあげるんですね
生きるために物が必要だからね
食べるもの 着るもの いろんなもの
住むところとかね そういう命を支えるために必要な部品
物質をね 上げてあげて協力した業で
今度は本人がすごい大富豪で
すべてもう嫌になるほど揃っている
貧乏はその反対で 人のものは取り上げる
あげるんじゃなくて取っちゃう
いわゆる盗む その業で人間に生まれたらすごい貧困で貧乏で生まれるんだと
そこで醜くなること 美しくなること
いろいろ高貴な家族で生まれる理由とかね
卑しい家族でなんで生まれるのかとか
それぞれまあそれぞれの業がお釈迦様説明してありますので
皆様は私より仏教を勉強なさってますから
結構勉強会やったりいろんなことやったりとかね
中部経典のチューラカマヴィバングスッタという番号は忘れちゃいましたけど
まあ調べない 全部暗記でやっちゃいますから
こういう作る場合はね
あの 我々暗記するときに
経典の番号とかね 関係ないんですからね
で えーと マハーカとか
あの後半に入っていると思います
中部経典のね 業の話した知りたければ
そこでお釈迦様は結論
プレースはカッマンサッテーヴィパジェティ
ヤリダンヒーナッパニータヤということ
意味はメイドバイ 命はメイドバイメイドイン
それからメイドウィズ
すべて業なんです メイドバイというのはあの業が作っているんです
メイドインというのは業の中でなんとか組み立てるんですね
メイドウィズというのは材料として業を使っているんです
という 2つの条件も業です
いわゆる制作者 制作所と含まれているもの
すべて業 業以外何もないんです
あ これ訳書いてないんですね
カンバンサッテーヴィパジェティ
生命を業が区別しますよと
ヴィパジェティというのは分けて分けてやる
区分けするんだよと 業がどのようにかというと
ヒーナッパニと まあ卑しい優れている
あれやこれやと すべての差が業がやってるんだよということ
それは訳してないんですね
生命はこうです だから
たと同一主にはなりません
これ業の働きなんですね
生命 例えば人間が 10人いるということは
10種類の業があることなんです
これは生命っていうことをだからすごく使ってますからね
ミツバチのところでね
まあ例えばまあ 5000匹ミツバチがいると
これは 5000の号なんです
だから私たちにはわからないんだけど
ミツバチも一匹一匹違うんです
個性を持っています アリもそうなんです
で見たらみんなワンパターンで生きているように見えますけどね
こんな個性がないでしょうと
でもアリたちが人間を見たら同じこと言ってますよ
カラスね 今日カラスは結構鳴いてたんだけど
生ゴミの時だからね で
カラスたちから見れば
まあ人間っていうのはワンパターンでね
水曜日は私が住んでるところは生ゴミの日だと知ってるんです
明日なくない？朝は だから我々はカラスはワンパターンと思ってるんだから
逆にカラスは人間でワンパターンやとね
だって生ゴミ食べようと思っちゃうとネットかけていると
ああ この連中はこんなもんやと
まあ法則違反やってるんだと
これは法則違反なんだよ
本当は食べる 食べられるものは食べられる
生命に食べ食べるチャンスを奪ってはならんですよ
で 我々人間の社会の状況によって
もうきちっと縛って ネットをかけて
あるいは私も蚊がありますからね
そこの中に入れて追い出すんですね
で 私はやっぱりこれって法則違反だなとかね
こちら食べられるものあるのにとかね
人間に食べられなくても
他の生命に食べられる
決していいことじゃないんですよ
それでも我々の社会にはいろんな問題が起こるんですよ
自然バランス崩しますからね
でも人間の社会はすごいワンパターンだから
もうそれ仕方がなく もう他のそこは誰も食べるなよということに
我々はまあブロックするんですね
ですから 言いたかったの余計な話で
我々人間の中で あなたと私は違うよと偉そうなこと言ってますけど
他人から見ればね だから皆様は知ってるでしょうと
アジア人が日本人や中国人
みんな同じやと思ってるんです
あれ どうやってお互い区別するのかと
同じことを皆様我々に言うでしょ？もうインド人やみんな同じで
だから私は特に あの人はパキスタン人
あの人はバングラデシュ人
あの人はスリランカ人と見ただけで言うんだけど
え？どうやって言うの？３人も同じでしょうと
そんなもんなんですよ
だから我々インド系の人々はお互い顔を見ただけでわかりますよ
民族もわかるし 国もわかる
で 皆様は日本人同士でお互いの顔を区別はしっかりしている
で 外国人にはよくわからないということになるんです
そこで それはどうでもいい話で
大事な話はこのポイントなんですね
一人一人が個です インディビジュアルです
似ている人はいないんです
これすごい大事なことなんです
なぜならば 我々は仏教を知らないんだから
似ている人を探しているんです
似ている人のフォーマット
自分も学びたいと思っているんです
人はどうやっているのか
そこを見てみて 見て 自分の人生を育てていくんでしょう
でもそちらに問題あるんです
決して悪いとは言えきれませんだけど
そんなことをやってもうまくいかないね
人の真似してしてね 人のやり方を真似て真似て頑張ってもうまくいかないでしょ
子供たちが芸術いろいろ習っている子供たちは
いろんな先輩たちのことをね
仰いで真似て一生懸命練習しますが
その人と同じくならないね
例えば一流の音楽家が世界で結構いるでしょ
でもベートーベンになれないね
モーツァルトにはならないね
作曲していますよ 結構あります
新たに作ったもの 新たに作ったものがあっても
あれはあれで これはこれなんです
皆様 何か一つのそういう曲を知っていますか？あのシンフォニー何か知っていますか？これはモーツァルトよりはすごいいいやという風に言えるもの
叶わない いい悪いを置いておいて違うんですね
現代人が何かシンフォニーを作ったら
それはそれなりの価値があるんです
楽器は違うしね 今は音の作り方が違うし
電子技術も使っているしね
ですから昔なかった音を今はいっぱいあるし
組み合わせも現代人がいろんな組み合わせをするし
それから世界的な音楽はもう交差していますから
今のシンフォニーだったら
まあその影響はあるんですよ
例えばマイケルジャクソンというのはまるっきりアメリカ的なロック歌手でしたけど
インド音楽の影響も何のことなく入っているんです
だからその曲はそれで素晴らしいんだけど
これとまるっきり同一曲作ろうと思っても
マイケルさんにしたってもね
あの人と同じどうしたら？それは無理なんですよ
やっぱり個性があります
いつでも だからそこを忘れちゃうんだから
人から学ぶのはいいんですよ
大事なポイントを忘れてはいけないんですね
これはお釈迦様しか言ってないんですね
みんな至って迷信で 簡単で
人間は神様が作った 他の人は自然に現れた
それだけ 人間が猿から進化した
はい さよなら 終わりと
猿から進化してもいいし
神が作ったってもどうでもいいんだけど
一人一人が違うということ
これはなぜ違うのかと
業という働きがあるんだろうと
この業という働きが人を作る
作る材料は何なのかというと業なんです
だから業が業で生命を作るんです
だから生命といったっても一つ一個の業の組織なんですね
はい この性向が何なのかというタイトルでね
と言われても性格を変えられません
だからみんなお互い互い違うでしょ
我々気に入らないところがあるのは
なんであんたこの性格は？とかね
なんとかならんかいとかね
特にお母さんたちがかなり神経質になって頑張ってますけど
無理 そんなのはどうにもならんです
これ知ってるお母さんだったら
すごい気楽に子育てするんです
だから仏教の世界では
あの子供育てるストレスはもう全くなかったんです
最近みんな仏教捨てたんだから
金だけ宗教としてるような人間になったんだから
自分の国でも 今はもう大変だ
大変だと言ってるバカがいるんです
だからブッダの教えを捨てちゃうと
もう大変危険ですよ だから安全で安らぎで生きられる世界ですから
そこを出しちゃうとね
皆様に関係ないんだけど
このブッダの世界で ブッダの文化で教えで指導ので出来上がった国だからね
3回も国全体あのサンガに寄付されてますよ
結局はサンガの財産ですよ
国全体 一般人が使ってるの
だから あの安全な枠から逃げてはいけない
まあ信仰は他の宗教あるのは構いませんだけど
基本的にブッダに説かれたあの安全枠から抜け出してはいけないんですね
そうなってくるとかなり問題はこれはこんなどうでもいい話で
あの母親が自分考えてるように子供の性格を変えたくなるんですね
母親が気に入らないことをやってます
しかし あれってどうにもならない
基本的には それはその子の業なんです
だから我々もね 会社であの人あれやこの人これやとかね
こんなこともう放っておけばいいでしょ
直らんだから 業を入れ替えることはできないし
自分の業を上げることもできないし
まあ例えばね まあソフトクリームとかアイスクリームとかありますね
まあソフトクリームは食べたいんだけど
あの乳製品嫌い 嫌いだから
それを取り外してくださいと
できる？できるわけないでしょう
なぜ自分のこのような性格ですかと聞かれても
自分でも全然わかりません
これが面白いポイントなんです
人に聞いてみて 人の性格だいたいわかるでしょう
なんであんたちょっとしたことにも興奮するでしょ
どんなことないところでも緊張するでしょ
あの性格って何？本人の性格だからね
本人わかる？わからないんです
というわけで 私は何か性格を持っている
が なんでこんな性格を持ってるんですか？別の性格の方がいいんじゃない？入れ替えたらと
それとわからないんだけど
業ですからね 他人が自分の性格を変えようとします
問題は他人が ものすごく迷惑かけるんですよ
自分を変えようとしているんです
これ変えられませんだから
これはお互い様迷惑ですよ
私のたとえで言えば 魚にお前泳ぐばっかりしないで歩く歩いてください
私は教えてあげますからと
魚に歩くことを教える
これって成り立たないでしょうに
これ 魚も困ってる ひどい目に遭うし
魚に歩く訓練をさせようとした人もバカを見て終わっちゃうし
特に動物の世界では問題ないんだけど
人間の世界になってくると
どうしてもこの人々は業のことも知らないし
心理も知らないし 何も知らない
ただ生きているだけで
人の性格だけ変えようとするんですね
自分は自分の性格を改良しようとする
これから自分自身でも自分の性格を改良しようとする
自分自身でやる場合は
まあ自由だからね 怒りっぽい人が頑張って怒らない人間になろうと頑張るならば
それは自由だからいいんだけど
私には怒りっぽい人の怒りっぽい性格を変える権利はないんですし
それできないんです 例えば
私の話を聞いて怒らなくなりましたと
あ あなた私の性格を変えましたと
私は変えてないんですよ
誰の性格も いろいろ仏教の話をして瞑想してね
もう人生楽になった方々はそれなりにいるでしょう
日本で あれ 私がやったんじゃないんです
一つも それは本人が自分の性格を変えただけなんです
そちらに無理があります
自分の性格を変えようとしても無理がありますから
気をつけてください とにかく後でそれなりに説明しますが
スライドは書いてないんですけどね
無理が皆様感じていると思います
例えば怒りっぽい性格
本人はこれってまずいなと知ってますよ
知ってるんだけど そう簡単に変えれませんね
なぜならば じゃあ怒らないようにしようと思って
それに怒るんです なんでややこしいんですかと
結局同じことになっちゃうんです
はい 人生っていうのはマニュアルがない複雑な機械です
人生はという主語は抜けましたけどね
人生はではないんです
命は 命とはマニュアルが存在しない複雑な機械です
命構成 命の構成も維持管理することも複雑です
命はどうやってできるのか
すごい複雑でしょうね
現代知識では この細胞のことを
DNAのことを知っているでしょうに
結構複雑なんですね 例えば細胞のことを知り尽くしているんだけど
誰かに細胞 1個作られる
細胞 1個だけ絶対不可能です
DNA って何なのかみんな知っている
では  1個作ってみましょうか
ありえないんです それは業が作るんです
人間にも神にもできることじゃないんです
しかし 皆 命の正しい取り扱い方法を説明するマニュアルを持たずに生まれるんです
ひどいことでしょう 皆さん持ってきました
生まれる時 私はこのように生きてみますとか
死ぬまでこのプログラムでチェックして生きてます
誰も持ってないんです
ただ生まれただけで これからどうしましょうかと
わからないんですね 神がこういうどんな馬鹿にも猿にでも使えるマニュアルは出してないんです
だから誰だって私はどう生きればいいんでしょうかねと他人には聞く
例えば私にも聞く 私もマニュアル持って生まれてこなかったんだからね
どうやって教えられますかね
だから私にできるのは
私の失敗の話と成功の話
経験を言うだけなんです
それもマニュアルにならないんですね
本来 生きるマニュアルなどは存在しないんです
生き方マニュアルは存在しないんです
人間には書けますけど
当てにならない あんなのは
人間は自分自身でマニュアルを作りますが
決定版はありません 我々人間
動物は作ってないんです
カラスは聖書を持ってないでしょ？カラスはどうでもいいんで
神様を作ろうがどうでも餌があれば食べて寝る
それで終わり 私たちはもう結構人生マニュアル生き方マニュアルを作るんですね
あの十戒とシャリア法法律ですね
は 神の直々の命令だと嘘ついているんです
嘘ついているのは マニュアルに権威を加えるためです
だから旧約聖書を読んでみると
モーセですね 十戒を神が教えるでしょ
だからそこら辺で まあその当時でもいろんな文化があったことだからね
まあエジプト文化もありましたしね
だからこのユダヤ人にとってはね
それを人からいろいろデータをパクるということはどうということはないし
そこは10項目にして
これ神様が教えてくれたとノコノコと思っている
だからこの人  3ヶ月間から山に隠れていたんだけどね
あれ何やと私は聞きたいんです
神っていうのはドッカンとはいはい出せばいいんだから
嘘でしょうか はっきり言えば
そこで恐ろしい法律でシャリアっていうシャリア法律は殴ったら殴れ
殺したら相手を殺せ 盗んだら手を切ってくださいと
女性が結婚していない男性と一緒にいたのを見つけたら
もう石を投げて殺せと
男の子とそれは大丈夫です
こんな法律って神が教えたんだから
その場合はとんでもない迷惑野郎がいるんで
ガーブリエルという ガーブリエルが直々教えたんだって
どうりで神じゃないんだけどね
とにかく シャーリア法律はアッラー神の指令であると言っちゃうと
権威が成り立つのです
でもハチャメチャでしょ
結局は だから十戒を守りなさいというのは
我々に生きるためのマニュアルなんですが
それ人生全体的に行き渡るマニュアルではないんですね
神との約束だけなんですね
十戒は 人間として この地球上でどのように生きれば正しいというマニュアルじゃないんです
生きるマニュアル お釈迦様もそういうこともありますよ
それはもう神のことでも何でもなく
理性で真理を発見して
こうでいいんじゃないかというふうに言っていることであれば
もう全体的に誰にだって実行できるし
もうブッダの機嫌を取るためじゃないんです
みんなこうですからね
個人だからね あんた 自分の人生をこのように
このマニュアル通りやれば
あんた幸せになるんだよと
試してみてと 試したらすぐ
正しいとあなた自身でわかるんだろうと
自ら確かめられる 確かめられると
そこで権は使いません
挑戦を使うんです やってみなさいと
こんな薬を飲んだら病気治りますよと
飲んでみなさいと 飲んだら治ったら文句ないでしょう
はい だからポイントを覚えましょう
業に作られた命ですね
しかし この命の運営 維持管理についてのマニュアルがない
これから教えます あの一言葉で
私は膨大なマニュアルを
その時思い出したら言います
途中でどのように脱線するか自分でわかりませんだからね
はい 次のタイトルに行きます
ノーフェイバリットというね
これ辞書を引いてみたら
フェイバリットというのはえこひいきでしたっけ？はないと
特別気に入りはない 業は個の持する自性ですが
その個を特別扱いしません
だから私の業が私を作ったんだから
私のことを大事に守る
それはないんです 放っておいてくれるんです
産んだだけやと そこで寿命も業が決める
美しさも体の色も業が決める
全部業が決める 富豪 幸福になるか
貧乏になるかも それも業が決める
だから その時の業のエネルギーによって命を作って放っておく
だから私の業が私のことを特別に可愛がってくれません
ということは 私を邪魔するか？それもないんです
業が意図的に私をいじめることもしませんし
意図的に私を特別扱いすることもしません
ですから この言葉大事ですね
ノーフェイバリットインカーマ
これいい言葉なんです
我々はやっぱり人に対して特別特別扱いしちゃうんです
これは私たちのやり方悪いんです
私が業であるならば すべての生命に平等に
対応しなくちゃあかんです
あんた可愛いんだから特別とかね
これおかしい 自分の村に川が流れている
これ例えばし この川をどのように使用するのか
村人の勝手ですね 川が意図的に誰かに恵みあるいは不幸を与えることはしません
そこで川と例えたのは業なんです
自分が村なんです 自分という村の中で川が流れているんです
川が流れているだけで
その川をどのように使うかと
村人の勝手です 川に飛び込んで死ぬこともできるし
川の魚を釣って食うこともできるし
川の水を持っていって田んぼを作ることもできるし
何でもできる 川は別に特別扱いはないんです
川で体を洗う人々を嫌がったりとかね
なんで汚い体を川に洗うんですか？とかね
なんで服なんか持ってきて
汚れた服をね 川で洗うんですか？と
それはないんです インド人みたいなガンジス川を拝んだってもね
ガンジス川はただの川です
そこでガンジス川を拝んで
ガンジス川の水を持っていって
聖水だと飲んだりするんだけど
遺体を半分焼けてそのまま川に捨てるんです
ガンジス川は別に特別扱いはないんです
そのように私の業がどのように使うかということは
私の勝手になります 生命の性格とその生命特有の業です
それで我々の性格というのは
私のところに流れる川なんですね
特有ですね で 業は理解能力を超える働きですが
発見できる業の表面は性格だと理解しましょう
だから業の話を持ってきたんだけど
業ってわからないんです
お釈迦様は人間が勝手に考えてはいけませんと
業の法則は これはもう思考範囲を超えているんだと
思考範囲を超えて無理をやると
思考自体が壊れるんです
要するに頭がイカレしまうんです
だから置いておいてください
しかし この業の表面だけは我々に分かります
表面そう すべてわからない
流産 流産でしたっけ？氷山
氷山のちょびっと上にある
あのちっちゃなところは見えます
でも下すごい山なんですね
氷の あの見える 氷山の何さんでした？グレイシアですね
でも上に見えるちょびっとは我々の性格なんです
だから性格ぐらいはわかるでしょ
人の性格がわかったら
それは業の 称賛のほんの浅かな一角だと理解してください
はい それから性格の構成について説明していきます
God が個人のために作った OS です
これはオペレーティングシステムです
OS の上に人は自由に APP をインストールして使っているんです
そこで分かりますよ 私はある性格を持って生まれる
それで私はいろんなことを学んで
この性格の上に乗せるんです
乗せてそれを使うんです
例えば言語に興味あるとか
人の言葉に興味あるという性格がある
あるだけ それで私がじゃあ英語を勉強してみよう
じゃあ中国語を勉強してみようとか
APP を入れるんです
基本的に人間の言葉に興味あるっていうところは必要なんです
それで その言語に興味がある人が
ある人が中国語の APP を入れちゃう
ある人はフランス語の APP を入れちゃうと
一人が中国語を喋ってそれで生きているし
一人がフランス語を喋ってそれで生きているんです
これはファーストランゲージのことじゃないんです
それはもうどうしたってね
言語一つも会わなくちゃあかんだからね
だって人間っていうのはいくつかの言語を学ぶでしょう
一般的な日本ではね あの
あまり上手じゃない すごい優れて
ものすごい能力ある方々いますけど
一般的に言えば あんまり他の言語を学ぶことに興味がないでしょ
それで学んでみようと思っちゃうと
ハチャメチャ苦労するんですね
だからそこはまあ性格でしょうね
なのに日本人で何か外国語をペラペラ喋るとかにびっくりする
能力にはそういう人もいる
それで 何か品物をからくりいじりたいという性格がある
いろんなものをなんかいじりたい
そういう人は何か技術を学んで
何かのエンジニアになるまでなるかも
それは APP ですね  OS は OS です
今皆様は大体携帯使ってるんだから
携帯の中に Android か iOS 10 とかね
Apple の場合は 2つで動いてるでしょ
そこでもう GOOGLE ストアか APPLE ストアからね
自分好きな APP を入れちゃうんです
入れて使うんです しかし
私たちは あれ 何でしたっけ？ Android プログラムをいじりませんね
それは変えません  APPLE 会社の iOS は変えません
ところがアクセスは不可能です
家族 育ち 教育 他人の影響
年齢 職業 住む場所などの様々な環境によって性格が変更します
これ全て仏教的に言えば APP なんです
自分が生まれた家族が自分のアプリケーションの一つなんです
だから自分の性格はうるさい家族のせいでいくらか変わるんです
それであまりにも嫌だったら
その人はどこか友達を作っちゃって
その中にいる 自分の OS に合う合う場所
で 教育っていうのはどういうこと？だから性格って OS の上に教育という APP を入れちゃうんです
でも見えるでしょ？数学がやりたがる人も
絵を描きたがる人もいる
教育世界がすべて提供しています
数学も文学も何でもかんでも
言語学も 何でも提供していますよ
しかし 学ぶ私が一つ選ぶんです
だから 教育者として数学者になる人もいるし
音楽家になる人もいるし
芸術家になる人もいるし
ただ何のことなくサラリーマンで終わる人もいるし
それから年齢によっても性格が変わりますよ
子供の性格はそのまま大人になってもあるわけじゃないんです
アプリによって変わるんです
それどう変わるかというと
携帯で考えてください
携帯に何 10万も もうもしかすると 1,000万ほどいろんなアプリあるんですよ
あるわあるわあるわ そこでみんな全て入れないでしょ？携帯にそんな容量ないんです
だからいくつか入れる
そういうわけで 私の携帯と隣の人の携帯が変わってるんです
アップによって そこでプログラムいじったりしてね
ゲームやりまくったりして
いろんなことでうまく動かなくなった可能性もあります
人生ってそういうものなんですね
性格という OS があります
その上にアプリを入れて入れて使っているんです
というわけで そんなに性格っていうのは理解難しくもないんですね
ただ はっきりしないだけね
音楽好きな人は あの子は音楽好きですね
じゃあ音楽やればいいんじゃない？っていう風に言えば簡単でしょ
あの人はもともと勉強嫌いね
だったら勉強というより
何か技術を学んだ方がいいんじゃない？とかね
で 性格に合ってるアプリを入れればいいんで
人生に 人は環境を管理することで好みに性格を変えます
これはすべて環境なんです
家族は環境です 教育って私は環境というんです
私の説明の場合は 例えば本を読む方々いるでしょ
本は環境です 本を読むと言っても
世の中にあるどんな本も読むわけないでしょ
選ぶ どんな本を読むのかと選んで読んでいるんです
だから選んで読んだ本によって
自分の性格が変わっていくんです
ということで 性格っていうのは日々変わるんです
変わるんだけど なんか変ですよ
なんかパターンがあるんですね
見違えるほど変わることはないんです
全く別の人になるぐらいは変わりませんね
そこで我々は生まれて持ってきた性格は何か自分でもわからない
だからそれは変えられません
しかし 私はそちらから刺激来るんですね
お前歌いなさい 歌いなさい
それ超気持ちいい やとかね
心が言うんだから じゃあ歌を練習して歌手になってしまう
そこは自分やるんです
そこで言いたいことは
例えば画家になれる性格で生まれても
その人の業が指令しません
お前必ず画家になりなさい
画家になったら大成功しますよと言っていく
それはない フェバリット様はないんです
それだったら楽ですよ
業の性格から見れば 画家の能力がある
だったら自然に自分が心が指令する
絵描きさんになります
その勉強しなさい その指令はない
だから私たちはそれなりに環境で何か選ぶ
あるいは環境によってそのチャンスがない可能性もあります
例えば私はちっちゃい時は音楽にすごい興味あったんだけど
環境はなかったんですね
学ぶところはなかったんです
どこにも だから変なおじいさんたちがいろいろ楽器弾いたり
いろんな歌って そういうところに行って学びたい気持ちもなかったし
母親が出してくれないしね
もし学校でちゃんと音楽のね
クラスがあったならば
もう母親に断る必要なく入ることできたんだけどね
でも環境がなかったんですね
そこはもうできなかったんですね
それで私 能力があるかないか
自分ではわからない やったことないんだから
ちょびっと興味あっただけ
そのように 業によって能力があっても環境がないと入れられませんね
そこで音楽はあまり好きじゃないんだけど
音楽や音楽家の家庭で生まれちゃうと環境でせ
でしょ？そうすると いやいやで子供たちもそれ学んでしまうんですね
それで仕方がなく音楽家として生活しちゃうんです
音楽は絵画じゃないんですよ
なんでうまくいかないかというと
業はその点では運で作って作り出したんだけど
君何やっても関係ないという態度でいるんです
フェイバリティズムはないんです
基本性格である業が邪魔しませんね
何やっても はい こんなもんですね
もう性格のことをだいたいわかったでしょうね
そんなに難しくないね
一般的に我々やってみればできますよという話があるでしょ
そうなんです 苦労するかも
例えば 本当に歌えない音痴
やってみれば歌えるんですよ
諦めないで その分 業の性格に過ぎてないんだから
結構苦労しなくちゃいけない
業は邪魔しません ちっちゃい時からもうあのあれ
absolute ピッチというものがあります
絶対何でしたっけ？あれは
音 絶対音感  音感 音感 ああ
これ絶対音感 ちっちゃい時しかそれつきませんだけどね
で ある人にとっては音楽
なんだこれって もうチャラ
もう簡単 ドとミの音の差が何なのかさっぱりわからない人でね
結構大変ですよ やればできます
でもその時間間に合う可能性もありますね
これ  20年も経ったとかね
だからまあ みんな思っているのは
自分に向いていることを学びたいでしょ
これわからないね 自分に向いている仕事をしたいんですね
その方が楽です が 業はあれないんだからね
行きないんだからね 音楽やら音楽やで言ってくれないんですよ
あんた音楽やりなさいよとかね
あんた高校学業とかね
言ってくれない 無関心でどうぞ好きなようにやってくださいって
はい それでセクションに座って次のチャプターに入ります
これ 私の考えでこの話進んできますけど
あれなんですね 色が違うね
個性ってそういうことで
このモニターで見える色とプロジェクター作り出す色っていうのはね
それぞれ個性を持ってるんです
今思い出したんだけど
なんで色が違う？で やっぱりこちらこちらの個性を持っていてね
あちらあちらの個性を持っていて
個人個人が違うんだったら面倒くさいんですよ
この分析分類できるわけないんです
結構難しいんです しかし
世間 世間ではね 性格分析というものって何か話がありましてね
エニアグラムという何とかチャート書いたり
あんまり私には面白くないんだけどね
面白がってやってる方々もいるしね
あんまり的には当たらないとは思います
しかし ブッダが人間に理解できない生命のエネルギーで
一切すべての生命 輪廻転生する生命のエネルギーは何なのかと見たところで
業を発見しましたからね
あるエネルギーを発見して
それに業と名前をつけただけで
業という名前はインドにあった名前で
ラベルでね そこからある程度で分析はしています
はい 分析の場合は基礎
仏教で基礎があるんですね
人は環境に応じて応じる方法で性格を発見します
では 私たちの場合は環境に応じているでしょ
それで自分の性格を見えます
いたって簡単ですよ いろんなところにいると
いろんな人々がいるところで
すぐ自分の性格見えてくる
友達と喫茶店に行ったら
超気持ちの人もいて 早く終わりたい
早く終わりたいと思っている人もいるでしょ
自分の性格です それはですから
皆様方は自分の性格を理解したければ
ご自分がその各時間で
各環境で心がどんな反応するのかと
ちょっとチェックしてください
メモを書いておいたってもいいんです
そうすると自分のあのわからなかった性格が見えてくるんです
そこから共通性を見出します
例えば喫茶店にいると
なんか超気分が良くてワクワクする
自分が それで自分だけじゃない
もう一人がいるんですね
なんか同じく調子に乗っちゃってワクワクしている
あ 似ている 同じじゃないが似ている
で そういう風にいろんなことを分ける
食べる 一緒に食べましょうと
で 食べ物を見たらものすごく喜んじゃって
よかった よかった こんなご馳走美味しそうだなとかね
えらい感動する人もいて
別にという感じでいる人もいる
自分がすごく感動しているんですけど
あれ 一人がいるんですね
もう その人も感動しているんですね
それで性格がそこで似ている
そこで性格の似ている人々は組合を作ります
似ているだけで同一じゃないんです
だから 例えば日本のお寺周りのグループ
今ないでしょう わかりませんだけどね
女の子たちがいろんなお寺に行って仏像を見たり
もう趣味でやって それでその同じこと好きな人々はグループなんですね
要するに自殺願望のグループまでいるんだから
だから自殺したがっている
もう一人自殺したがっている
性格は同じじゃない 私が自殺したがっている理由と
あの人は自殺したがってる理由は違うんだけど
自殺したがってるんだから
じゃあ仲間 お互いに助け合って自殺しましょうってことになっちゃうんです
はい それから分類できますね
性格改良プログラムは社会の一般的な価値観に合わせて作ります
そこで性格改良するというね
直すという考えがありましてね
一般社会もそう思っているんですよ
あの人の性格を直さなくちゃあかんやとかね
精神科にカウンセラーに出さなくちゃあかんやとかね
カウンセラーやら精神専門家やらね
性格を変えようとするんですね
その場合はあんまり大したことじゃないんです
社会が決めたプログラムなんですね
社会に迷惑のない人間作りたいだけなんです
しかし 成功する確率は高くないんです
社会で この世界で性格改良するプログラムは結構あります
でも何か腹があるんですよ
一般的には 例えば政府が犯罪者を認めません
なぜならば もう自由に好き勝手に活動すると政府には迷惑なんですね
人間がロボットのようにイエスマンでいれば十分です
だから決まり決まりいっぱい作って
それにハイヤッハーイエスって認めるならば OK です
この国は平和ですと言うんです
そこで政府が勝手なことを決めても
私は反対 守りませんと言うと
面倒くさい この人の性格を変えなくてはいけない
昔あったケースなんですけど
君が歌う時はもう歌うなよとかね
立ちませんとか 何か反対していた人々はいたんですね
何だこれはとか 大きい大げさな問題にしちゃってね
君が歌う時は誰だってちゃんと規律にして
何とかしなくちゃいけないんだと
そうやった方が楽でしょ？やらないとめんどくさいね
そういうことで じゃあカウンセラーのところに連れてきます
カウンセラーがこれは国の国家だからね
もう国を大事にしなくちゃか
あれやこれや国って何か分からないしね
で 日の丸に頭を下げたからといっても全然わからない私も
私わかりませんだけど
私も自分の国の国家を歌うときは一応立ちます
普通はお坊さんたちは立ちませんだけど
私は立ちます 別に国はなんとなんと思ってもないんですけど
まあなんとなく まあみんなやってることで
まあ一応国の国家でしょうね
国の国旗でしょ それは立って歌終わるまでじーっと立っている
なのに時々政治家が一緒にいるんだけど
あいつはいい加減であれ見たり
こちら見たり 携帯見たり殺したくなるんですね
だって政治家が国の金食ってるのに
あの連のためのために立ってるのに
それは携帯見るんで 国家が歌ってる間で
ある前の大統領なんですけど
何か講演やってると 国家に入ってる文章を引用したかったんです
みんな仲良く平和でいなくちゃいけないという言葉がありましてね
この人 これ間違ったんです
考えられる？大統領なの
もう前の 国家の文章間違っちゃう
あのリリックスを もう追い出さなくちゃあかんですね
あの性格は まあどうでもいい話で
そこで私たちはみんな一つにまとめようという腹があるんですよ
みんなロボットにしようと
そうすると このちょっとそのプログラムに入らない人
入りたくない人がいると
あなたの性格は変えなくちゃあかんやと言って洗脳するとか
カウンセラーのところに行くと
例えば北朝鮮の人々はみんなもう金系だけ神様やっていう風に洗脳するんですね
洗脳されちゃって 人権を全部奪っちゃって
ただ生き物 言葉を喋るんだから
動物ではありませんという程度にしちゃったんです
それでみんな気持ちよく動物でいるんです
喋る動物で 誰かが北朝鮮でなんで投票ある場合は同じグループだけ当選投票当選するんですかと
私も出たいんだと思っちゃうと
その場で殺されるでしょ
そういうことで この今はちょっと大胆な例を出したけど
学校でも性格を変えるプログラムもある
みんな一緒にまとめてまとめましょうと
国にもある 国際的にもある
国連もいろいろなことを考えている
しかし 私が言いたいのは
あまり成功しないね あまり成功しない
それで仏教のアプローチ
仏教は性格の表面的な現象はそれほど重視しない
ちょっと無関心 私も時々言われますけどね
なんであんたああいうああいう性格なのに
その人に何も言わないんですかと
あまり言わないんです
迷惑な時はちょっとあんた声がちょっとでっかすぎやという場合は
けど それもすごく言いたくないんですね
声がでかいのはその人の本来の体の特徴だから
ちょっと声控えてくださいって
その人苦しいんですね
だから仏教的にはあまりそれは言わない
社会はこの表面的に性格をすごい重視するんです
それ変えればいいと思っているんですね
性格の基本は業ですが
それは人間の理解範囲を超えているので
それも重視しない 仏教の性格改良プログラムでは
あまり業だ業だとか言って
強情な話を持っていかないんですね
3 業を知り尽くした釈尊の教えをマニュアルとして使って
性格の発見と改良に励みます
そこでお釈迦様が一応マニュアルを作っているんです
性格はどうでもいいんだから
おっしゃっている通りやってみてくださいと
物の見事に元から性格が改良していくんです
例えばね 人間喋ることにはごちゃごちゃ言いません
自由に喋ってください
しかし 嘘はやめてね 嘘をやめて
陰口もやめてね 無駄話もやめてみたらどう？とかね
それはごちゃごちゃ喋ってもいいんです
そうすると本来すごい喋る人間でね
この口が達者な人間なんですが
それは変えません よう喋る人
結構かっこよく喋る お釈迦様が言うのは
まあそれはいいんだけどね
それは表面的ところだからね
嘘はちょっとやめて 無駄話やめて
陰口やめて まあいい それで終わり
まあ助ですけどね 微妙なんですね
それをやめてみると 業のところから性格が良くなっていくんです
成功する確率ははるかに高い
例えば言葉の 4つの悪をやめた
1個だけ言葉を気をつける
やってみてください 確実に成功する
自分がすごく立派な人間になっているんです
智慧が現れて 落ち着いて
悩み苦しみもなくなって
みんなに好かれてすごい楽ちんになっちゃうんです
よ 一個やってみたっていうのは
稀なケースで失敗するが
改良が不可能なケースもあります
仏道をやっても失敗するケースもありますけど
稀 だから仏典でそれも派手に記録しているんです
失敗したケース 隠していないんです
お釈迦様はアドバイスして指導したのに
何々さんが出て行っちゃったと
減速して帰っちゃったと
それも記録しています
お釈迦様が喋ったのに
ベロを出してお釈迦様はバカ軽視して帰っちゃったとか
そういうケースもあります
でも仏教の場合は稀なんです
あるいは改良不可能 場合もありますね
今あまりいい例はできないんだけど
例えば仏教でいう１５ ５
つの十災あるでしょ？母殺し
父殺しとかね やったらアウトで人格改良はできないんです
アジャースチェサとアジャースという王が父親を殺しちゃったんですよ
それで悩んで悩んで悩んで
父親が仏教 悟った人なんで
ビンビサロは 悟った人を殺したことは
お釈迦様はすごく気に入らないんですね
だってそのビンビサロは王をやめて
息子にあげたんです あんた若くて政治やりたければどうぞ
私は引退しますと 言って
普通に家の中でご飯食べて奥さんと一緒にいたんですよ
なのに 周りがね やっぱりあの人がね
元の王だから みんな尊敬しているんだ
その人のことを 尊敬するでしょうに
だから死んだ方がいいやと言って
だって今日本の天皇もね
まあ辞めようと思っているでしょ
辞めたからといって一般おじいさん扱いする？誰もしませんよ
天皇陛下の立場はそのまま
それでも法律的にないかもしれませんだけど
でも国民はそれでも 尊敬をしますよ
これどうにもならん だから殺しちゃったんですね
それですごくもうひどい目に遭って
本人がやがてブッダに会ったんです
会って喋ると自分の悩みがなくなったんだけど
苦しみもなくなったんだけど
やっぱりブッダの教えは素晴らしい
正しいとも分かったんだけど
お釈迦様がその若い王が帰るとき
こう言うんです あいつはね
あの聖なる父親を殺さなかったら
帰るときは悟って帰るんだよと
お釈迦様に初めに会ったんです
だいぶ経ったの中年でしたからね
お釈迦様に初めに会って喋って帰るでしょ
その間で悟りに達することができたんだと
でも無理 もう父親を殺したんだから
そういうことで この不可能なケースもあります
次 行為は業になる理由
生命は身口意で行為します
あの なんで仏教は業という言葉を使うかというと
あの業には意味 2つあるんです
今説明しているわけのわからない業
生命を維持管理するエネルギー
これわけもわからないね
もう一つ カンマっていうのは行為なんです
誰だって知っている そういう誰だって知ってる行為に
特別に業という別な意味を入れてるんです
ダブルミーニングで使っているんです
いつでもダブルミーニングです
今 私が喋ってるでしょ？それも行為
それは行為でしょ？パーリ語で業というんです
しかし 命を育てるエネルギーのことじゃないんです
行為は行為だけで留まらず
業というポテンシャルになります
例えば喋ったら喋った
疲れた 終わっただったらありがたいんだけど
そうじゃなくて 何かポテンシャルが残るんです
皆さんも感じていると思いますよ
例えば人を怒鳴るでしょ
人にギャッギャッと その時わけもわからなくて
感情的になってギャー
だって喋るでしょ？喋ってから何か残らない
あの嫌な味がずっと残るんです
あれが業なんです 行為とその結果が理解しやすいのですが
業になった時の働きは理解できません
行為と結果はわかります
例えば人を殴ったら その人を痛いし
殴った私も痛いし 私は怒っているし
私の怒りの結果でその人が怒っているのも行為の結果でしょ
私が怒った 殴った 自分も痛くなった
殴らなかったら痛くないでしょ
で 相手も痛くなった 怒った
それで相手も怒って もう 10倍殴る
私に殴り返す 私はもうあの人にちょっぴりした痛みしか出てないんだけど
こちらはもう病院に連れて行くはめになったり
それぐらいわかります
理解できないのは この業になったこと
ポテンシャルになったこと
例えば殴り合いで 私は一発しか殴ってない
相手にクタクタやられちゃった
病院まで行った 行って 2 日間入院もしました
それで終わらないんですよ
ポテンシャルが残っているんです
それはそれなりの結果を出します
このポテンシャルは この死後も死後に結果出す場合もあるし
今世でも体変えるんですよ
だって業が体作るんだからね
殴られて それで私はすごい恨み憎しみを持っている
退院しても持っている
それで私は訴えてやろうと思っちゃう
ここまで怪我しましたからと
言ったら 根端から言ったら
先に手を出したのは私ですから
警察はすみませんね それはできませんと言っちゃう
で 警察に対しても怒ったりする
それで私の体も言葉も家族環境も生き方も
じわじわと変わっていくんです
どういうことかというと
もしかすると今まで結構食べていたのに
あまり食べられなくなるとかね
食べたらすぐお腹が壊すとか
いろんなことになるんですよ
それは科学的に説明はできないんです
今世でも細胞たちの動きが変わるんです
遺伝子たちのプログラムが変わるんです
それは科学では発見できないんですから
明確に発見できません
仏教はそれはポテンシャルというふうにしていますね
無明と渇愛という 2種類にして見ることもできますね
あ 何か一つ抜けました
心に貪瞋痴という感情があるから
行為は業のポテンシャルになってしまいます
わかりやすいね 私は喋ると貪瞋痴があると業になるんです
貪瞋痴がなかったら喋った
終わった 疲れた それで終わり
水一杯飲もうで終わり
貪瞋痴があるとポテンシャルが溜まるんです
というわけで いたって簡単
答え身口意の行為は貪瞋痴の感情があって
やるとすべて業になります
あるいはお釈迦様の経典から渇愛と無明という 2つに説明することもできます
人が渇愛と無明を持っているならば
喋ること 考えること やること
すべて業として溜まりますよと
ポテンシャルとして溜まりますよ
それは人間に理解できない世界
科学では決してこれからも発見できない世界
科学はこの人の遺伝子が変わったと
この人はがんになったと
あの人の遺伝子読んでみたら
もうがんになる可能性はものすごく 60%あったんだけど
今は 80歳でまだがんになってないよと
これは何だと言ったらわかりません
業です 業が 遺伝子がどんなプログラム使った方がいいかと決めているんです
遺伝子はただの物質です
はい 次に行きましょう
まあちょっと時間取りすぎ
感情の組み合わせ 貪瞋痴と...となくなっています
反対の働きである不貪不瞋不痴もありますが
一緒に行動します どうしても何かあったら反対もありますからね
だから貪瞋痴の反対もあります
不貪不瞋不痴 反対のもの一緒には活動しませんね
当たり前 しかし ポテンシャルとして業になります
例えば不貪あるでしょ
あれは貪りあったんだから
反対の不貪が生まれたんです
それをポテンシャルで業になります
貪瞋痴だけじゃないんです
不貪不瞋不痴も業になります
環境によって貪瞋痴と不貪不瞋不痴は強くなったり弱くなったりもします
そこで私が持っている貪瞋痴
不貪不瞋不痴は 環境によってまた変わるんです
例えば あまり欲がなくても
何かいい環境で美しい環境で楽しい環境に入っちゃうと
自分の欲がちょっと強くなってくるんですね
みんなお互い悪口言ったり
喧嘩しているところに行くと
自分の怒りもちょっと強くなる可能性あります
環境によって それによって業が変わりますよ
だから悪業したくないんだけど
悪業をやってるグループの中にいると
もうやってます 悪業は溜まってるんです
個人にどうすることもできないんです
それをお釈迦様おっしゃるんです
仲間を選べと それはできます
人に悪口言う 噂ばっかし言う
人を軽視する 見下すグループがいたら
そちらの性格でグループの出来上がっているんです
そのグループに入らないこと
良い言葉を喋るグループに入っているんです
そうすると自分がポテンシャルが善業になるんです
その影響は業が受けますね
だから貪瞋痴 不貪不瞋痴で感情があって
行為するたびに業が影響を受けます
受けて業そのものも常に変わっていくんです
業というポテンシャルがずっと変わっているんです
この複雑さが性格にも表れます
我々の性格に表れますよ
例えば怒りっぽいと言っても
その人は 24時間怒りっぽいじゃないでしょ
優しい人間になる場合もあります
人を助ける場合もあります
例えば私は知ってるんですけど
昔はね ヤクザのグループに入ってる人々
ヤクザだから悪人じゃないんですよ
結構優しいこともやっちゃいます
結構人のことを他の人よりも心配したりするときもありますよ
だから性格はなんで複雑かというと
この貪瞋痴 不貪不瞋痴のこの絡み合いの結果なんです
性格に良し悪しはない
良し悪しは感情の問題です
性格はただ性格ですよ
ですからね 性格は業なので
ポテンシャルが合理的で正しい結果を出しています
あれはただのエネルギーですから
エネルギーによって正しい結果を出しています
エネルギーでしょう 例えば
バーナーで何かに火をつけると
氷が現れないでしょ バーナーをガスバーナーを何かに当てたら
与え当てられたものが燃えちゃうんです
合理的な結果です 例えば人がバーナーを持って人の壁に当たる
壁が燃えて火事になる
我々はとんでもないことをやったと判断するんだけど
行為は正しい結果を出しただけなんです
性格の良し悪し 判断は人の主観です
例えば すごく言葉荒っぽい人がいる
で 初めからもうそういう性格があって
日本語を学ぶ場合は やっぱり品格のない言葉だけ気に入っちゃう
気に入っちゃって そればっかり使う
敬語は使わない 敬語使っちゃうと気持ち悪くてたまらんですね
だから厳しい単語だけ使う
そこに善悪言わないでください
良し悪し言わないでください
その人はの業が正しい結果を出しているだけ
しかし 我々の感情で なんでこの場であんな単語を使うのかとかね
あなたの性格悪いと私たちは感情で主観で判断するだけです
結果が好ましいか否か
社会が認めるか否か 個人が気に入るか否かなどの判断です
性格の良し悪しは社会は認めません
だから私の性格が悪い
私はこんな性格は嫌ですねとか自分で言う場合は
自分の判断で悪いとなるんです
性格に悪い良しはないんです
面白いことはね 時々私たちは自分自身の性格も気に入らないとかあるでしょ
面白くない？それは自分自身の性格なのに気に入らん
こんな性格はとかね 例えば食べたら食器を洗わない
たまる 気持ち悪いんですよ
本人にも気に入らない
でも洗わない それでなんで私はこんな計画でしたと
なんでこんな怠け性格ですかと
やめませんね それでも
だから我々はね 私の性格だと言って威張ってるわけじゃないんですよ
時々は嫌な性格ですね
私はという風に思う時もあります
性格は折り紙を色分けに区分するようなものです
はい これから性格をちょっと説明します
しかし 皆様方 これは折り紙の色分けするような感じでやりましょう
良し悪しは関係ない 色紙のたくさん持ってきて
折り紙の折り紙 色がありますからね
これは色で分けてくださいと言っちゃうと
何のピンク色はピンク色にして
青色は青色にして 白いのは白にすればいいんです
私は白い好きだから白いだけ取り上げますとか
これはダメなんです はい
次に行きます 差別は罪です
障害者 健常者 白人 黒人
黄色人 知識的 感情的 活発
親分型 子分型などの性格がありますね
よくありますよ それは業が合理的な結果を出しているだけです
業がただ結果だっているだけです
良し悪し判断 特に差別的な感情は個人が犯す重罪です
人が生まれたら黒人です
その人の業ですからね
良しでも悪しでもないんです
あんた黒人でしょうと思った途端
言った私が罪を犯しているんです
よく人間やっても知らないうちに結構罪を犯しているんです
この差別感情っていうのは
必ず相手の性格から現れるものなんです
性格が原因で現れるんです
みんな様々な性格を持っている
差別だけはやめましょう
あの人クリップやあの人はちょっと暗い
あの人は活発とかね あの人は説明する前に判断にするとかね
冷静に言ってほしい あの
あの折り紙の色分けのような感じで
たまに母親はそれをやるんですね
上の子が勉強好きですけど
2番目はいつも遊んでいるばっかりでね
勉強あまり好きじゃないねとか
でもお母さんとして 2人も可愛い
あれ 差別してるわけじゃないんです
そのような行為は自分の業になります
差別したら自分の業になります
色分けをするような気持ちで性格分析に進めましょう
はい これから性格分析に行きます
これは判断しないでください
基本的な性格分類 これは仏教の話だけです
1ラーガチャリト愛欲という単語を使ったんだけど
その意味でもありません
2ドウサタリト怒りと書いたんだけど
怒りという意味でもないんです
3 モーハチャリト 痴 無知の痴
4 サッダーチャリト 信ですね
5 ウィタッカチャリト
読めない 探求？尋求？ 尋求
尋求とか  尋求 なんかコピーしました
ディクショナリから  6 パンニャーチャリト
英ですね で これは説明ですね
このラーガチャリタっていうのは欲ばっかしということじゃなくて
明るい 美を好む ちょっと汚れてる
さっさと綺麗にします
綺麗にしないでいられない
人と会って紹介されると
先にその人いいところ見つかっちゃって
ああ いいね あなたの服がすごいかっこいいやと
そんな風に行くんです
いいあんた髪型面白いね
結構似合いますよとかね
そんな風にアプローチするで
これはこの愛欲という意味でもないんです
しかし 愛欲性格ある人もそのタイプなんです
激しく愛欲がなくても
人を見ると あ あの人 あんた
あー覚えた すごい面白いかっこいい髪型の人でしょ？なんか面白い服を着た人で
そこで覚えてるんです
そこで性格はプラグチャリタということになるんです
どうせチャリタっていうのはもういつでも怒りっぽいという意味でもないんです
怒りっぽい人もどうせチャリタですけど
対立的に 例えば髪型が
なんであんたこの髪型
顔に合わないでしょ？もうちょっとショートにカットした方がいいと思う
対立して これは怒り型なんです
短所気になる 先に短所を見つかるんです
3番目 モハチャリタっていうのは無関心
普通 あまりまあ別にという感じで無関心でいる
ちょっとあのね この人でもうちょっと仲良くしてくださいよと
それから役に立ちますからとかね
ああ そうですか じゃあ頑張ってみるという風に
その場合は 髪型の短所も長所もあまり気にしないんですね
無知型というんですね
あ 間違った それからサッダーチャリタ信
それも明るいんですよ
サッダー人はあんまり物事深く深くいかないで簡単に信じる
あ そう はい わかりましただけで
あんたそんなこと言われたって
もうちょっとそこまでいかない
あの よく騙される人々いるでしょ？もう振り込め詐欺やらね
いろんなことで  そこほどないんだけど
昔日本でものすごい問題あったんだからね
あの訪問販売ということを習慣があって
結構騙されちゃうんですね
あれ 新型の人々は簡単に乗ってしまいますよ
だから信って あの宗教的な信仰という意味ではないんです
宗教的な信仰の場合はこの信じゃなくて
あれは無知で ほとんど
何でも迷信信じらを信じると
自分の利益のためにやっているんだから
ほとんど無知なんです
こちらでは性格タイプだから善悪はなし
ただの色分け あ また間違った
5番目ヴィパッサナーチャリタ沈空
この人も対立的なんです
こう言ったってもそうならない
こういう風になるんじゃない？こういう風に見方があるんじゃない？とかね
なんとなく対立っぽく見えるんです
本当は対立じゃない 違うものを見えてくる
ただ対立する人は怒り型
だから対立したからといってすごい気をつけないと色分けできないんです
この人は対立しているんじゃなくて
違う見方 違う見方を教えてくれる
調べないと気が済まない
逆に明るい 本人がまた明るい
とにかく調べてみて あ
納得ということになるんです
調べるまではイライライライラ
まあよくわかりません
だからこれから調べますよとか
で  6番目はパンニャー
知恵の性格ですよ 知恵の性格で言っても
この人々を見ている中
無関心な顔をしているんですね
とんであれこれとはないんですね
しかし ひらめきが早い
みんないろんな議論をやって
もう困ってるのに無関心でいる
参加しない議論に それで議論があんまりも言っていて
もう壁にぶつかってくると
あのね こうすればいいでしょ
はい終わり もう無関心
それからわかってるんです
わかっているのは議論から答えひらめたんです
そういう性格 大体そんな
これは基本的な 6つ 問題は
この性格が組み合わせて使っているんです
あの料理と同じ ご飯食べたいからって
誰が真っ白いご飯食べる？食べないね
組み合わせ あのチャーハンという料理あるでしょ
かわいそうにご飯をいじめること
油つけていろんなものをつけて
ひどい目に合わせて 食べるんですよ
じゃあ皆様 白いご飯を選ぶ
チャーハンを選ぶ チャーハンを選ぶでしょ
おかずも何もなく白いご飯がある
おかずも何もなくチャーハンがある
どちらにする？チャーハンにしますね
そういうわけで あの 本当は仏教のアビダンマの話です
今やろうとしているのは
仏教はおかしな人のことを判断しないでくださいと
性格判断すると あなた方は寂しくなるんだと
すると罪を犯すんだと
性格は難しいんだと 性格を理解できるのは
完璧に理解できるのはお釈迦様だけなんです
から 私たちも仕事を徐々にやらなくちゃいけないんです
仕事上やるんだけど それの膨大なことを勉強するんです
勉強して性格を発見するんだけど
それでも人に言わないんです
僕はそれをすごいプライベートにしているんです
あるミャンマーの若いお坊さんなんですけど
結構 1ヶ月ぐらいいろいろ仲良くしていて
もう一人の人がいたんですね
この人はいつでも手がかかるんだけど
すごい優しく面倒見てあげて
私はこの帰ることになったところで
この若者 20代にもなってないと思いますけどね
私に何々さんがね こういう性格ですねとすごく優しく言うんですね
言った途端 私はびっくりした
この若者がわかって 私もわかっていたんだけど
言わないんだから 誰にも
あ なるほど 若いお坊さんだけど
ちゃんと性格呼ばれ読まれているんだと
読まれて そこを理解した上で
どう助けてあげればいいかということだけ考えているんですね
これ難しいんです 難しくなっているのは
この組み合わせなんですよ
白いご飯よりはチャーハンを選ぶ
その場合はね 化学調味料を入れているわ
もうね いろんなもの 性格違うものを混ぜてるんですね
他の性格も組み合わ組み合わせて自分の性格になります
あ そうですか なんか師匠
の時間なくなったみたい
えーと 組み合わせる ですから
最低でも 36種類になります
例えば ラーガ 欲の性格と動作が組み合う
智慧の性格を組み合わせるとかね
他は全部 6は 6で組み合わせたら最低でも 36になります
我々はもっと組み合わせているんです
物事に対して自分のアプローチを調べてください
だから自分のアプローチを調べてください
そうすると 自分の複雑な性格
システムが見えてくる
ある時は機嫌がいい ある時は機嫌が悪いとかね
ある時はすごく頭が鋭い
ある時は言っても言っても理解できないとかね
その時 無知の性格で頭がすぐ鋭い時は智慧の性格で
そこでどんな回数 どんなパターンが現れるのかとわかったら
それが自分の性格なんです
そこであるパターンがつかみ見つかります
それがあなたの性格です
性格の改善について語っていきましょう
強い欲と合理的なアプローチが欠かせない
性格はそう簡単に変えるものじゃない
だから強い意志と合理的でなければ
基礎性格はそのまま基礎性格は OS のようなものなので
個人にアクセスすることはできません
あの業が作ってくれた性格は変えられません
もう生まれているんだからね
それは変えられません
性格を巧みに使うことで幸福になれます
しかし 自分の性格を巧みに使う
だから合理的でなければ
例えば 怒りっぽい人がどこかもうもうゴミ処分でもすれば
環境を綺麗にしましょうと
ゴミを処分しましょうとかね
そういうふうなところに行けばいいんじゃない？それで性格に合わせて社会の役に立つ
例えばもうついもう怒鳴ったり人を脅したりする性格がある
その人はこの犯罪をやっていてね
少年院なんかにいる子供たちのアドバイスに任せばどうですかね
なんかいたずらと何という一言言ったら
みんなビビっちゃって
そこで役に立ちます で
使い方は釈尊に説かれていますので
それに従って実行することだ
とにかくお釈迦様の教えを見て
それぞれ実行してみてください
自分の理性と実行しやすい方法を見いだしても
良いが感情で判断して仏道を改良しないこと
ですから 仏道では言っていることはそのまま実行できないかも
だから性格から見て これならできる
これができるというところからやってほしい
こんなのはやりたくない
変えますはダメなんです
それで道 ちょっと省略して一つだけ言います
道っていうのは性格を変える道
仏道ですね これ 基本的な解脱へという 3段階にしています
善から始める善行為から性格を変えたければ
改良したければ 善行為で始めてください
それから五戒守ってみる
これは誰にだってできる
どんな性格でも 五戒守ると自分の性格に直接は当たっていないんです
だからあなたの性格悪いと仏教は思わないんだから
あなたの性格悪い あなたの性格良いとは思ってないんです
これは業が作ったプログラムだから
だから性格はどうでもいいんだから
五戒を守ってよと すると性格はしっかりと直っていくんです
それから慈悲喜捨の瞑想をするとかね
あるいは呼吸瞑想するなど
心整える 落ち着いている訓練する
それで業がきれいになっていくんです
パンニャー智慧とはヴィパッサナー実践などですね
ヴィパッサナーのやり方もかなりたくさんありますし
まあそれ好みのやり方でやってみてほしい
こういうプログラムでしか性格は改良できません
ほんと項目ごとに書けましたけど
膨大な量になるんだから
すべて今日は省略しました
自分で気になっている性格に一発
気になっている性格に一発で直したいという欲望は合理的ではない
我々失敗するのは 1 日で性格直したいんですね
これだけなんとかならないのかとか
それは欲望ですね 放っておいてください
放っておいて 着々と成果を上げてみてください
で 順番も釈尊が説かれていますから
その順番でやってほしい
あれ 戒定慧順番でしょ
はい ちょっと理論喋ります
基礎性格は変えない 業を変えようと無理をしない
性格を構成する貪瞋痴を変えていくんです
業は変えません ポテンシャルだから
貪瞋痴を変える ます不貪不瞋不痴の行為で挑戦する
感情煩悩が智慧でなくなるまで進んでほしい
不貪不瞋 例えばヴィパッサナー瞑想をやっていると
その時間 10 分 ヴィパッサナーの実況中継をやると 10 分間不貪不瞋不痴なんです
それも質の良い不貪不瞋不痴なんです
ここをやってやってみてください
派手な変化を感じないんだけど
じわじわと変わっていくんです
感情煩悩が最終的になくなるまで
要するに 業に性格を構成することはできなくなるんです
業に人を作ることはできなくなるんです
この粘度がなくなっちゃう
だから業があっても繋げないんです
感情で繋げるんだから
接着剤は感情です 煩悩を根絶で
相対的貪瞋痴も不貪不瞋不痴も超えます
そこで貪瞋痴に相対的で不貪不瞋不痴がある
貪りがなければ不貪もないんです
お互い様は必要です 怒りがなければ慈しみが成り立たないんです
相対的なんです 悪がなければ善がないんですね
そういうわけで この相対的不貪瞋痴不貪不瞋痴から相対を超えた状況にならなくちゃいけない
それで性格完了です で
感情が消えたら 業に新たなプログラムを作ることはできないんです
もう接着剤なくなっちゃった
業はあるんです ポテンシャルだから
でも繋げません 命を しかし
今の肉体は過去の業なので
それはそのままになる
今の肉体はどうしようもない
悩み苦しみ しかし悩み苦しみ
消える 安穏で生きられる
例えばひどい体で生まれた
障害で苦しい体で生まれた
でも瞑想してもう乗り越えた
性格を完成しました そうすると体はいまだに苦しいんだけど
別に気にしない 肉体壊れたら終わりますからねって
すごい安心感でいられる
感情はない 例 歩けない人が悟りに達しても歩けないんです
黒人は白人になりませんよ
黒人瞑想して悟ったら白人になったとかね
基本は変わりません だから我々は性格を完成するんだけど
性格新たな性格になるわけじゃないんです
ということは みんな阿羅漢になっても個人の差があるんです
そのまま 皆様 あの 80代の弟子たちのことを知ってるでしょ？サーリプッタ尊者がすごい智慧の方で
モクレン尊者はすごい瞑想の達人で
サーリプッタ尊者にも悟ってるんだから
モクレン尊者と同じく瞑想の能力があるかというとないんです
それは変わらないです
例え話 自分の性格は一つの食品だとしましょう
自分の義務は与えられた食品で完成な完全な料理一つ作ることです
あのひと作ってほしい
すべてのディナーを作る必要はないんです
一品 ナスをもらった人はナスの料理を作るのであって
肉料理を作るのではありません
出来上がった料理は完成品であることです
これは性格に合わせてください
皆様の性格は皆様に与えられた食品です
1個 あるいは 2個 あるいは 3つぐらいもらっている
それで料理作ってほしい
例えば豆腐だけもらうってことは性格の複雑でしょ
豆腐という食品をもらったところで
お醤油ももらうかもしれませんし
油ももらうかもしれませんし
もう玉ねぎももらうかもしれませんし
また何か何か それで考えて
どんな料理にするのかって自分でやらなくちゃいけない
作った料理は完成した作品
文句言えない 立派な料理でなければいけません
こういう風に人格を育てていくんです
例えばチキンもらった人がね
チキンと玉ねぎといろいろもらったついでに豆腐ももらったと
どうしますかね？豆腐捨てる？捨てません
豆腐も入れて何かチキン料理を考えなくちゃいけないんです
それでも問題あります
与えられた食品という性格は様々です
例えばにしてわかるでしょ
一人がナスもらって 一人がジャガイモもらって
一人がメインにチキンもらって
一人がメインに魚もらってとかね
またその他何か揃っている
それで料理しなくちゃいけないんです
泥だらけのごぼうをもらう
その人はごぼう料理する前に泥を洗わなくちゃいかんですね
切って洗った魚もらう可能性もあるし
そのまま魚丸ごともらう可能性もあります
野菜の種と畑もらう 何もない
その人は残念ながら畑で種を植えて育ててから料理を作らなくちゃいけないんです
とにかく完成した食品を作らなくちゃいけないんです
もみだけもらう人がそれを食べられませんでしょ
その人にいろいろ方法で籾を米にして
また他もらったものでご飯を作ることもできる
あるいは籾を田んぼで植えて
大量に米を収穫して これを売って料理買うこともできる
方法はいろいろ もみを使わないで田んぼで植えておこう
それから稲刈りをしてたくさんもらっちゃって
これ余り売る 売ったら金が入る
その金で料理買う いいコックさんが作った料理を買ってもらって
はい どうぞと これもできる仕事やったんです
しかし 与えられたものからやったんです
時々金だけもらう人いますよ
材料として その方が一番楽ね
そのように人間の中で
人間 各人の完成した料理を作る過程が変わるでしょう
苦労して時間をかけて解脱に達する人も
楽に解脱に達する人もいます
私はこの完成した料理と言ったのは解脱なんですね
いわゆる人格を完成しました
性格を 個性はある 個性はあるんだけど
完成した その道がある人に
例えばダールチーリエというバーヤという仙人がたった 2分
お釈迦様に会ったのはたった 2分で悟ったんです
智慧の第一人者であるサーリプッタ尊者にも何年もかかったんです
そういう人は様々です
業は性格です それはもう変わりません
諦めない 人間なら皆良い業を持っています
我々はみんな良い業を持っています
業は資金のようなものです
投資して大富豪にならなくてはいけません
愚か者が資金で食べて不幸に陥ります
自分には自分特有の宿題もあります
それをやることが業の投資です
えっと ちょっと説明しましょうか
この我々は性格として業を持っているでしょ？業はクール
えこひきしませんが すごい親切で宿題は与える
みんなに朝から晩まで宿題はあるんですよ
例えば目が弱い人にはそれが宿題なんです
目が弱くてもどうやって幸福に生きるのかと
それであの弱い業が改良するんです
結婚した相手がものすごい性格悪くて荒っぽい
それが自分の宿題として見て乗り越えなくちゃいけないんです
逃げても意味がないんです
逃げたとは宿題やってない
だから業のいいところは
我々は常に何か宿題がある
何か解決しなくちゃ 問題
問題意識 それしっかりやってみてください
すごい幸福になります
だから 自分の業が食って終わるものじゃないんです
投資するんです 私はある人にわかりやすく言ったんですよ
誰だって あのアメリカの大統領誰でしたっけ？トランプさん
誰だってトランプさんみたいに金持ちになりますよと
それぐらい業持ってますよと
投資しなくちゃあかんです
ビルゲイツさんも普通の人でしたからね
そんな貧乏な家ではなかったんだけど
そんなにはちゃめちゃ金持ちの家でもなかったんですけど
自分の能力を投資して
世界の億万長者になる
これは金はどうでもいいんだけど
自分の業を投資して解脱に達してほしいんです
ありのまま危険というのは
ありのままとは貪瞋痴に身を任すことですね
貪瞋痴は人を堕落へ導きます
煩悩と対立することは難しいですが
先行です だからありのままというのは貪瞋痴で煩悩できることです
それはやめてください
ちょっと難しいんだけど
対立して戦ってほしいんです
解脱とは煩悩を完全壊すことです
貪瞋痴を壊すんです その人は聖者であって
もはや人間ではありません
それで人格の問題は解決です
もうわかったという人格完成するということは
みんな均等になることでもないんです
肉体を持っている間は個性はありますが
解脱というところでは完成しています
はい 話はそれで終了です
で やり方は皆様いろんな本を読んで
どうやって自分の性格を直せるのかどうかね
性格に当たらないでください
性格は良いでも悪いでもないんです
ただの基本フォーマットだけです
それをうまく使ってください
ただ 私は本当は普通は無口なんですけど
でも何か喋りたいなという気持ちがあったんです
それでその性格をそろえて
今説法しているんです
はい 終了しましょうか
時間的にはもう終わったんですね
今日も質問の時間はなしでね
もうすぐ  はい これでもう終了で
早く終わると思っていたのに
はい じゃあしゃべりますか？ 大丈夫です
では 最後の誓願 はい 唱えましょう
ドゥッカパッタチェニンドゥッカ
バヤンパンタチェニンバヤ
ソウカンパンタチェニッソウカ
ホントゥサンデーピパニノ
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます